Este es mi minuto de gloria,
mi discurso de aceptación,
y este es el pato.
Esta es la primera vez que viene a la costa oeste de Estados Unidos.
Lo voy a pasar para que lo vean.
(Risas)
¿Bueno?
Pueden pasarlo unos a otros.
Por favor tengan en cuenta que es un espécimen de museo,
no hay ningún riesgo de contraer la gripe aviar.
Después de ganar este premio, mi vida cambió.
En primer lugar, la gente comenzó a enviarme
todo tipo de asuntos relacionados con los patos
y obtuve una muy buena colección.
(Risas)
Más importante aún,
la gente comenzó a mandarme sus observaciones
de comportamiento animal peculiar,
y créanme, si hay un animal que esté comportándose mal en este planeta,
yo lo conozco.
(Risas)
Este es un alce.
Es un alce tratando de copular
con la estatua de bronce de un bisonte.
Se encuentra en Montana y ocurrió en 2008.
Aquí tenemos un sapo que trata de copular con un pez dorado.
Eso ocurrió en los Países Bajos, el año 2011.
Estos son sapos de la caña en Australia.
Este es un animal muerto en el camino.
Por favor noten que se trata de necrofilia.
La posición es notable.
La posición del misionero es muy rara en el reino animal.
Estas son palomas en Rotterdam.
Golondrinas en Hong Kong, en el año 2004.
Este es un pavo en Wisconsin
en los terrenos del instituto correccional juvenil de Ethan Allen.
El acto llevó todo el día,
y los prisioneros lo pasaron muy bien.
¿Qué significa esto?
Me pregunto:
¿Por qué ocurre esto en la naturaleza?
Bueno, llegué a la conclusión
estudiando todos estos casos
de que es importante que esto suceda
solo cuando la muerte haya sido instantánea
de manera dramática
y en la posición adecuada para permitir la copulación.
Por lo menos, eso es lo que creía hasta que obtuve estas diapositivas.
Aquí Uds. ven un pato muerto.
Ha estado muerto 3 días
y está tendido de espaldas.
Así que ahí falla mi teoría de la necrofilia.
Otro ejemplo del impacto
de los edificios de vidrio sobre la vida de las aves.
Este es Mad Max, un mirlo que vive en Rotterdam.
Lo único que hacía este pájaro era volar contra una ventana
de 2004 a 2008, todos los días.
Aquí lo vemos, y se lo muestra en este corto video.
(Música) (Golpe)
(Golpe)
Este mirlo
pelea contra su propia imagen.
En ella ve a un intruso en su propio territorio,
y vuelve todo el tiempo y él está ahí,
es una lucha sin fin.
Estudié esta ave un par de años y pensé:
¿no debería tener daños cerebrales?
No los tiene. Les muestro aquí algunas diapositivas,
algunos cuadros del video,
y en el último momento antes de golpear el vidrio,
pone sus patas de frente,
y entonces golpea contra el vidrio.
Así que terminaré invitándolos al Día del Pato Muerto.
Es el 5 de junio de cada año.
A las 6 menos 5 de la tarde,
nos reunimos en el Museo de Historia Natural de Rotterdam,
sacamos al pato del museo,
y tratamos de descubrir nuevas maneras
de evitar que los pájaros se estrellen contra las ventanas.
Y como saben, o quizá no lo saben,
esta es una de las principales causas de muerte
de pájaros en el mundo.
Sólo en Estados Unidos, mueren 1000 millones de aves
estrelladas contra los vidrios de los edificios.
Y cuando terminamos, nos vamos a un restaurante chino
y cenamos pato.
Así que espero verlos
el próximo año en Rotterdam, Países Bajos,
para el Día del Pato Muerto.
¡Gracias!
(Aplausos)
¡Oh, perdón!
¿Me pueden devolver el pato por favor?
(Risas) (Aplausos)
¡Gracias!